[Music]
2018 hasn't exactly been a smooth year
for bachelor Ari lion Dyke jr. first
there was that whole thing where he
dumped his fiancee Becca on TV to get
back with his runner-up Lauren the more
I don't know with you the more I felt
like I was losing the possibility of
maybe reconciling things with Lauren and
now it appears he's dealing with a whole
new kind of backlash stemming from an
April Fool's joke Ari shared this photo
to Twitter on Sunday a seemingly
pregnant Lauren showing off her bump in
a tight purple dress he wrote in the
caption secrets finally out we have a
bunny in the oven but a mere 90 minutes
later re-tweeted wolf fools the joke
didn't exactly go over well several fans
criticized the prank as insensitive to
those struggling with fertility issues
calling the joke quote distasteful and
sick et spoke with Ari the day after he
proposed to Lauren live on after the
final rose he told us he has no regrets
I think this brought me here with her
and you know this is this is why I came
on the show to meet someone like her and
it's made it all worth it
[Music]
[Applause]